[Música]
el huracán Ian se degrada categoría 3
después de haber tocado tierra en el
suroeste de Florida como una tormenta de
categoría 4 calificada como una de las
más poderosas registradas en Estados
Unidos y han ha dejado sin electricidad
a más de un millón y medio de hogares en
el estado más de dos millones de
personas recibieron órdenes de
evacuación
Tal como se esperaba las autoridades
separatistas anunciaron El Triunfo de
los referendos realizados en las
regiones ucranianas controladas por
Moscú para anexarlas a Rusia y ahora
piden al kremlin que oficialice la
medida Estados Unidos prepara nuevas
sanciones por dichos referendos al
tiempo que anuncia nueva ayuda militar
para Ucrania
y este 28 de septiembre se conmemora el
día de Acción global por un aborto legal
y seguro Aunque algunos países de
América Latina flexibilizado su
legislación son muchos los que aún la
criminalizan y la estigmatizan este
jueves se registraron marchas en varios
países
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
con noticias del huracán Ian que se
degradó a categoría 3 según informó el
Centro Nacional de Huracanes la tormenta
que Había tocado tierra en el suroeste
de Florida como categoría 4 ahora
registra vientos máximos sostenidos de
185 kilómetros por hora y han catalogada
como una de las tormentas más poderosas
jamás registradas en Estados Unidos ha
dejado a más de un millón y medio de
hogares sin el servicio eléctrico siendo
formales y Cape Coral los más afectados
con fuertes corrientes de aire e
inundaciones el gobernador ronda Santi
sugirió que la marejada ciclónica había
alcanzado su punto máximo pero que
probablemente infligiría daños en todo
el estado
a medida que esta tormenta pase por su
comunidad entiendan que es una situación
muy peligrosa van a tener líneas
eléctricas caídas para tener la
posibilidad de sufrir daños debido al
agua estancada el mal uso de los
generadores por favor tomen precauciones
obviamente se acerca una tormenta feroz
muy peligrosa muy amenazante sabemos que
es un peligro para la vida pero una vez
que la tormenta se va una vez que hay
una calma aparente todavía habrá muchos
peligros por ahí
antes de tocar tierra en Florida Ian
causó devastación en Cuba causando la
muerte de dos personas y afectando el
sistema eléctrico y dejando a oscuras a
toda la isla de acuerdo con medios de
comunicación locales el centro y el
Oriente del país han visto un avance en
la reconexión del servicio de energía
mientras que la situación sigue siendo
compleja en el occidente donde la
restauración será lenta
cambiamos de tema el gobierno de
Nicaragua declaró Este martes como
persona no grata a la embajadora de la
Unión Europea en el país una medida que
se da como paso previo a la expulsión de
la diplomática de la nación dirigida por
Daniel Ortega la decisión llega luego de
que la semana pasada Bruselas instala
Ortega ante la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas a restaurar la
democracia por lo que representa y en
Ucrania las autoridades separatistas
anunciaron El Triunfo de los referendos
de anexión a Rusia a pesar de las
acusaciones de ilegitimidad por parte de
la comunidad internacional y Ucrania se
espera que el presidente Vladimir Putin
anuncia la anexión oficial de los
territorios en los próximos días
con sonrisas aplausos y abrazos de
Victoria así a celebraron los líderes de
las zonas separatistas de Ucrania y la
misma Rusia la victoria de los
referendos de acción
[Aplausos]
ahora podemos decir totalmente
razonablemente el don Bass es Rusia lo
fue y lo será con apoyos entre el 87% y
el 99% en las cuatro zonas en las que se
realizaron los referendos Donnie es
lugans zaporiya y gerson ahora el
siguiente paso es unirse a Rusia algo
que lo representantes de las zonas no
han tardado en pedir estimado Vladimir
Vladimir
le pido que considere la cuestión de que
la República Popular de lugans pase a
formar parte de Rusia
la legitimidad de estos referendos ha
sido puesta en entredicho por Ucrania y
sus aliados occidentales ya que se
producen en plena guerra pero a pesar de
las críticas al proceso Los observadores
Internacionales que se desplazaron a la
zona han dado validez a los referendos
desde el punto de vista democrático no
tengo nada que decir en contra de este
referendo
mientras que anunció que juzgará a los
colaboradores ucranianos del referendo
como traidores por secundar lo que
tachan de fraude absoluto e injusticia
la participación es del 15 al 30% de los
habitantes de la ciudad y de ahí tomaron
los resultados cualquier matemático
diría que no es matemáticas sino
fantasía
en las zonas de los referendos como
lugans muchos ciudadanos ven esperanza
en la anexión a Rusia
espero que haya paz y prosperidad espero
que la gente no se mate estoy orgulloso
de vivir en Rusia
ahora se espera que el presidente
Vladimir Putin anuncia la anexión de los
territorios en los próximos días y ya
advertido una cosa cualquier intento de
reconquista ucraniano será visto como un
ataque a Rusia y un octavo paquete de
sanciones contra Rusia propuso la Unión
Europea a raíz de la invasión al
territorio ucraniano este último paquete
incluye restricciones comerciales más
estrictas más sanciones contra
personalidades destacadas o allegadas al
gobierno y un límite al precio del
petróleo este octavo paquete es
propuesto cuando Rusia ha respaldado a
los referendos de anexión en el este de
Ucrania y hay indicios de Sabotaje en la
operación del nord Stream 1 y 2
es una respuesta a lo que la ue
considera un intento ilegal de acaparar
tierras y cambiar las fronteras
internacionales el miércoles la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
vonder Legends propuso una nueva serie
de sanciones contra Rusia
No aceptamos el falso referéndum ni
ningún tipo de anexión en Ucrania y
estamos decididos a hacer que el kremlin
pague por esta nueva escalada esto
mantendrá los productos rusos fuera del
mercado europeo y privará a Rusia de
unos ingresos adicionales de 7000
millones de euros
bajo las nuevas restricciones
comerciales ciertas tecnologías de la
Unión Europea que podrían ayudar a la
maquinaria de guerra de Rusia ya no se
exportarán y también habría
prohibiciones adicionales para la
prestación de servicios europeos las
nuevas sanciones también Proponen
incluir en la lista negra a más personas
y entidades rusas además proporcionaría
una base legal para un tope al precio
del petróleo ruso el g7 que incluye de
Italia Francia y Alemania ya acordado en
principio imponer un tope al precio al
combustible para terceros países esto
significa que los países participantes
tienen gran servicios occidentales como
los seguros a los cargamentos de
petróleo cuyo precio supere el límite en
mayo la unión continental acordó dejar
de importar el llamado oro negro ruso
que llega por mar desde finales de este
año pero a otros países como la India y
China no se les ve la intención de parar
de adquirir el petróleo ruso también
sabemos que algunos países en vías de
desarrollo siguen necesitando algunos
suministros de petróleo ruso pero a
precios bajos este tope del precio del
petróleo ayudará a reducir los ingresos
de Rusia por un lado y mantendrá estable
el mercado Mundial de la energía
europea tardó cuatro semanas en aprobar
su última ronda de sanciones sus líderes
tienen previsto debatir las últimas
propuestas el viernes
es que las recientes fugas en los
gasoductos nerd Stream 1 y 2 en el mar
Báltico podrían tener consecuencias
medioambientales graves así lo han
indicado expertos quienes dicen que
podría tratarse de la mayor fuga de gas
metano que haya sido registrada hasta la
fecha dicho gas contribuye en el efecto
invernadero es decir contribuye al
calentamiento global esas pequeñas
burbujas verdes que escapan de estas
grandes tuberías
esta estas de gas natural el 90% del
cual es metanol poderoso gas de efecto
invernadero se considera que es
responsable de casi un tercio del
calentamiento global por lo tanto estas
fugas son una mala noticia según la
asociación medioambiental los amigos de
la tierra El metano es un gas con un
poder de calentamiento entre 84 y 87
veces superior al del co2 en un periodo
de 20 años y a lo largo de un siglo su
poder de calentamiento es unas 30 veces
superior al del co2 Es difícil decir
cuánto metano liberarán estos gasoductos
según los expertos si el North Stream 2
contiene 300 millones de metros cúbicos
de metano solo una parte acabará en la
atmósfera ya que al entrar en contacto
con el agua el compuesto químico se
oxida y se transforma en CO2 en función
de la presión en los gasoductos entre
180.000 y 270 toneladas podrían ser
liberadas una cantidad importante pero
que en realidad solo representa
alrededor del 1% de las emisiones
anuales de metano si hay algo que estos
sabotajes han puesto de manifiesto es el
riesgo de estas emisiones de metano han
aumentado casi un 10% en la última
década y el 22% de ellas proceden de la
explotación de petróleo y gas y este
miércoles y Jordania vivió la jornada
más violenta de lo que llevamos de 2022
una redada israelí terminó con cuatro
muertos algo que los israelíes han
justificado alegando que la autoridad
Palestina no hace suficiente para frenar
a las milicias de la zona Alba Santana
tiene los detalles
es una de las mayores escaladas de
violencia que la zona en mucho tiempo
todo ocurrió muy rápido en medio de una
redada de israelí en jenning se activó
una bomba Palestina y empezaron los
tiroteos
fuego cruzado que se saldó con la vida
de cuatro palestinos
una explosión Así que fui directamente
al balcón y me iría abajo me di cuenta
de que esos vehículos pertenecían a las
fuerzas especiales y atraparon a Beth
hassen
fue uno de ellos hermano del hombre que
mató a tiros a tres personas entre la
viven abril ahora su padre como muchos
otros en la zona enfrenta el entierro de
su hijo
lo que ha ocurrido hoy no ha sido una
redada normal no ha sido un intento de
detener o matar a mi hijo ha sido una
verdadera batalla
los comandos israelíes buscaban a dos
sospechosos por participar en ataques
contra israelíes y de las víctimas tres
pertenecían a las filas y uno era un
agente de la inteligencia de la
autoridad Palestina un episodio que se
ha consagrado como la heredada más
violenta en lo que llevamos de 2022
hoy hemos recibido 32 heridos en el
hospital número que coincide con el día
que recibimos más heridos el año pasado
esto demuestra la magnitud del asalto
algo que una vez más pasa factura sobre
todo a la población civil Palestina
aterrorizada tras el incidente
como residente de Jenny no veo ninguna
Esperanza ni un futuro
la operación rompeolas que busca acabar
con las milicias palestinas y hacen
cobrado la vida de al menos 70
palestinos y hoy 28 de septiembre se
conmemora el día de Acción global por un
aborto legal y seguro Aunque algunos
países de latinoamérica han
flexibilizado su legislación son muchos
los que aún lo prohíben más en el
siguiente informe
una lucha que se mantiene cada 28 de
septiembre se conmemora el día de Acción
global por el aborto legal seguro y
accesible América Latina ha tenido
importantes avances en cuanto a la
legalización de la interrupción del
embarazo sin embargo aún genera debate
creo que es un día muy importante
especialmente para nuestra región en
[Música]
lamer donde no se tienen las mismas
provisiones legales alrededor del acceso
al aborto no y y justamente frente a los
avances que ha habido especialmente
Durante los últimos años pero que
igualmente siguen existiendo
retrocesos o intentos de retroceso
América Latina tiene grandes contrastes
en cuanto a la regularización del aborto
recientemente países como Colombia
Argentina y siete de los 32 estados de
México obtuvieron una flexibilización de
la interrupción del embarazo Pero hay
otros estados donde el panorama es
incierto países como Haití y El Salvador
prohíben el aborto de manera absoluta en
este último se castiga a las mujeres
hasta con 50 años de cárcel y 12 al
personal médico que realice la
intervención por su parte Honduras
además de prohibir el aborto castiga
incluso la anticoncepción oral de
emergencia en Perú desde 1924 hace casi
100 años la ley del aborto se mantiene
rectas otros países como Venezuela y
Nicaragua aún están muy lejos de llegar
a un consenso mientras Ecuador Brasil
Paraguay y Bolivia permiten el
procedimiento bajo ciertas causales
porque los estados tienen que cumplir
independientemente de quién está al
mando es con sus obligaciones
internacionales frente a garantizar el
servicio de aborto para todas las
personas que lo necesiten pues Porque
además es justamente se trata de que no
tiene que ver con que si estamos de
acuerdo o no con el aborto a nadie se le
está obligando a que tengan aborto se
trata que es un servicio de salud
esencial que cualquier persona en edad
reproductiva puede necesitar a lo largo
de su vida Aunque cada vez hay más
acceso a la salud reproductiva en la
región es una lucha por la cual el
movimiento feminista no se cansa de
batallar
y a los 59 años de edad murió El rapero
estadounidense Julio una de las
personalidades más importantes del hip
hop durante la década de los 90 según
informó su manager el artista falleció
en la casa de uno de sus amigos en la
ciudad de Los Ángeles aunque no
especificó Cuál fue la causa Julio era
reconocido por su éxito gangstar
Paradise y por el que obtuvo un premio
Grammy en la categoría de mejor
interpretación de rap en solitario
[Música]
de esta manera despedimos esta
Informativo en francés 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]